[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
on Harper when you just finished you can
use the equipment oh that's your job I'm
just here for the astrological benefits
that's not a thing
just hurry up we need to get moving and
we're going to miss the meteor shower
dude chill on you're going to get this
behind [ __ ]
just let you look like it with me
this plug is just a bug bite or
something
[Music]
[Music]
okay are you guys going in there uh yeah
why do know rock the dark and don't
stray from the trail ski/walk will come
for you mean my golf
skinwalkers they roll here right well
we're in a hurry but thanks for the one
do you draw with our rose poisoning or
keep that in mind
thanks they advise but we really need to
go tastiest just in case thank you
this is the right way it should be here
[Music]
Riley Riley
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for watching
skinwalker if you enjoyed this film
please give this video a like also let
me know in the comments what legends
you'd like to see us cover in future
videos a lot of weird stuff happened
during the production of this film
eventually I'm going to do a true fear
episode documenting and when I do I'll
drop you a link right here until then
check out my other horror films and mis
playlists and subscribe to see these
worlds for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive